Hey! You again.
Natalie.
Isn't it literally ironic how we run into each other every day?
Good sir!
Allow me to define ironic for you, fellow.
There's verbal irony, dramatic irony, and situational irony,...
...which is the one you speak of.
That's the incongruity of the actual sequence of events...
...and the normal or expected outcome of the sequence of events.
So when you say that running into your friend every day is ironic,...
...it's not ironic, it's just interesting.
Irony taught!
What? Who are you?
I'm Captain Irony, here to educate the masses on the use of the word "irony."
Hipsters love me.
I've always wanted to know how to use the word "irony."
I never really met anybody that knows...
Shush, wait!
So, you don't even have the power to restore balance and your catchphrase is "irony taught"?
A captain without superpowers.
Now, that's ironic.
No, it's not. Believe me.
Ironically, sometimes I think it'd be nice to not have powers.
Did you just hear yourself?
You just put the word "ironically" in front of a totally unrelated sentence.
That's like saying, "Ironically the ocean is neat!"
You know what's ironic?
A captain who's a woman, am I right?
Oh, that's so funny to me.
Really?
No, I was being ironic.
Irony taught!